how is that touring with billy eilish
well billy that's my dog you know she
seems super chill oh she cool as [ __ ]
but like what is that like because
you're um
your stage presence is insane your music
is extremely like i feel like it's built
for like live
environments right but that's a
different type of vibe right like man
there's a lot of little girls just the
whole thing with the billy hondas tour
it just opened my eyes to like what i
could possibly be doing you know
so what i mean by that is like i was
doing venues and clubs and stuff like
that right right you know that's pretty
much easy for me very successfully i
might add yeah thank you yes but when
i got to do those arenas it was
different i see what kanye west was
talking about when he went on tour with
youtube like he wanted to make music for
like arenas and [ __ ] like that
so with her giving me the opportunity to
open up for her own tour
i felt like that was gangster because
like i never heard my music in that kind
of environment before
so it made me look at my music
differently
it made you kind of like
i feel like there is there is a
such thing as like making music for
arenas like we think of like people like
oh this is a festival record this is
going to go crazy in front of coachella
like so now when you go in and you
record certain records you'll have that
in mind because you've actually
been through it yeah i mean a lot of
that [ __ ] is like synth heavy and bass
heavy you know what i'm saying and i
just want to be able to have the crowd
sing my lyrics because to be honest with
you like i'll be rapping fast and then
i'll be saying big words and people like
i'll give these all these type of
metaphors and sometimes it hit and
sometimes it miss and people be like
what the [ __ ] you talking about denzel
you know it's never like real straight
up but with just me working now i feel
like melody is always going to win like
we know songs just based off the melody
like a b c d course you know all that
[ __ ] you could hum it and you'll be like
i know what that is no twinkle twinkle
little star same [ __ ] how would someone
hum ultimate
so was billy alex just a fan of you and
like what like was it her idea like how
did that happen because that's kind of
she's young you know um
all right it happened in 2016 fyf that's
when she came to my show for the first
time i'm like one of her favorite
rappers okay and i didn't even know i
was one of her favorite rappers until
she told me in 2017 because that's where
we've met officially
and the first time we met we was at the
studio we were you know supposed to work
on the record it was me her and phineas
and
we didn't even make a record we was just
cracking jokes the whole time we went to
go get a acai bowl go eat we were just
you know
talking to each other just you know just
cutting up then our relationship started
to build more and more over time is you
know as time progressed and [ __ ]
and basically you know she came to the
studio and worked on sirens which is
with me and jade on a taboo on record
yeah yeah you know shout out to billy
she seems to be like someone who's like
despite all the fame and being one of
the biggest you know pop stars in the
world she seems pretty like
every time i see her talking or doing an
interview she seems like a humble cool
chick bro she's down to earth as [ __ ]